au bourg
bienvenue sur diagonale télé on va voir
aujourd'hui un autre champion d'échecs
du 20e siècle avec jérôme bour france à
l'europe c'est les femmes on va parler
aujourd'hui d'un champion donc voyez un
peu le nombre difficile prononcer max
lever ou peuvent donc moi je dis ouais
tu dis ça s'écrit eu une double v e donc
alors heurts ont fait était hollandais
pourtant c'est pas trop commencer par le
hollandais est d'accord en flamand on a
un peu séché les cours et on a du mal
l'allemand on peut avoir des idées mais
le hollandais pape allemand c'est pas un
problème mais le néerlandais s'est
parfois un peu compliqué en tout cas lui
est beaucoup plus simple que sont à
prononcer puisque fisher jugé max
pleurer comme trop normal pour être
champion du monde il ya 17 ans mais il
était trop normal pour être champion du
monde
d'échec il n'était pas assez hors norme
c'est quelqu'un qui reste le moteur tout
se vit jamais été professionnel du jeu
il a réussi à conjuguer une carrière de
professeur de mathématiques et sa
passion pour les échecs tu as toujours
été pris entre raison et passion et il a
été le champion du monde dont la dans
leur règne a été le plus court puisqu'il
n'arrivait que deux ans nous et c'est
très court de 1935 et 1937 le temps de
ravir son titre à halle et kid et de
berne le match revanche alors fait à
noter notamment de perdre le match
revanche qui n'était pas forcément
automatique parce que c'était à
l'initiative bon john challenger le
challenge est champion ça c'est une
chose mais du champion aussi d'accepter
donc il n'était pas obligé d'accepter de
faire un match de dingue mais comme il
est effectivement il était champion
d'échecs
j'ai presque envie de dire à ses heures
perdues il a au contraire tout à fait
accepté de rejouer le match entre andy
keane est nul c'est un homme d'une
grande probité donc ils n'auraient pas
vu l'intérêt de
d'empêcher les kings de tenter sa chance
à nouveau c'était pas le genre de la
maison c'était quelqu'un de courtois
gentleman quelqu'un qui voulait toujours
trouver le consensus explique aussi
qu'il était par la suite président de la
fédération internationale des échecs
oui ce qui semble d'ailleurs là je crois
presque le plus grand legs qui nous a
donné parce que donc c'est pas ça car le
sentiment très courte qui qui remarqua
mais plutôt son règne en tant que
président de la fidl fait l'art
international puisque là il va rester
quasiment presque dix ans oui de 70 1977
1978 voilà donc on lui tend un période
difficile une période difficile puisque
c'est la grande période de
l'affrontement est ouest avec fisher
l'arrivée karpov le dissident workflow
s'était astreint à compliquer agir il
fallait un diplomate
quelqu'un de quelqu'un de faire reculer
et c'était bien le cas du docteur il
s'appelait louis docteur max avait alors
dans cette période 70 78 qui est des
nouveautés dans l'un des échecs
l'introduction du classement elo c'est
quand même une grande nouveauté
alors oui c'est là qu'en 70 a lieu en
1970 saluent la publication du premier
classement elo d'ensor le premier est
évidemment bobby fischer qui est notre
fameux classement mondialement connue
maintenant elle repris dans d'autres
sports même le foot maintenant comment
savent qu'ils vivent façon alors je
savais pour le tennis et le tennis de
table le pardon le classement féminin de
la fédération internationale de foot
dégradé équipe nationale de foot la
france l'allemagne les etats-unis les
grandes équipes
il y en a moins que encore que deux pays
bascule un qu'il faut [ __ ] mais quand
même bon paquet bien d'autres
cinquantaine et bien se fait avec le
classement et au par exemple cette
dernière coupe du monde de foot que
l'urne mal les usa avec un classement
elo de 2190 lorraine donc ça permet de
se faire une idée de la force des
nations entre elle et le classement donc
effectivement a été mis en place grâce à
en partie donc un médecin qui dirigeait
la fédération ce moment là on a vu
d'autres choses à gérer dans cette
période là on pense au match de 72 entre
l'office sur l'espace qui casse qu'il
fallait réussir à concilier non pas la
chèvre et le chou mais les exigences
soviétique et les exigences américaines
volets notamment tricheurs il a fallu
aussi qui gère des problèmes comme le
fait que fisher ne veulent pas défendre
son titre en 75 en tout cas s'occuper de
sa destitution
alors ils volent et ses potes alors
figaro ses potes qui voulait pas jouer
dans ces conditions on va être en
diction
voilà donc jamais pu être remplies ouais
bah il a posé des conditions telles que
l'emplacement n'a pas pu être organisée
c'est max goff qui à la fin a décidé de
destituer fischer de son titre de
champion du monde en 1975 c'est dans
peut-être là où ce v10 ou cédant
simplement à son idée du jeu et du jeu
amateur c'est à dire de ne pas poser des
conditions non plus win
et puis la lazio cette décision peut
être qu'on teste table d'un point de vue
de la force fisher hall a été peut-être
encore fort suffisamment pour battre car
coffre en 15 ceci dit quelle légitimité
pour preuve à faire ça parce que
lui-même avait accepté de jouer un match
revanche contre ali qui donc on peut
difficilement lui reprocher de ne pas
s'être appliqué à lui-même ce qui
demandait aux autres absolument et il a
aussi fait preuve de courage en
soutenant des joueurs dissident
soviétique comme ce sont nos co qui l'a
défendue contre bien sûr la vie et le
courroux de puissantes fédérations
soviétique
donc il a su prendre aussi des positions
qui ont donné une certaine indépendance
à la fédération internationale vous le
regrettez aujourd'hui on peut regretter
aujourd'hui de ne pas voir ce genre
d'homme à la tête de la fédération
depuis 78 oui il faut qu'on peut
regretter c'est vrai qu'après son 18c
campo malaise qui a pris la suite
et la fédération pinsolle perdu beaucoup
de sa de sa légitimité
ce qui s'est aggravée avec avec le
désaccord avec kasparov dans les années
90 qui a qui a créé une période de grand
trouble dans la lignée des champions du
monde de l'organisation du championnat
du monde alors revenons à mach seul qu
alors max heures venez en quelle année
quand même se déroule sa vie à bord est
il né en 1901 dans une petite banlieue
rurale eux à côté de laval star one
c'est un symbole brc les terres gagnées
sur la mer par les néerlandais on sait
qu'ils beaucoup de paul vers le pays bas
et il vient d'une petite ville de
banlieue construite sur un polder
il est d'une famille juive est tout à
fait tout à fait simple et dans une
communauté qui est assez qui est assez
importante aux pays bas et il suit des
études de mathématiques tout simplement
et les pays-bas à l'époque sans vie qui
scientifiquement à plusieurs prix nobel
il ya lawrence qui a été prix nobel est
un grand biologiste qui s'appelait de
fries aussi ou qu'on n'a plus beaucoup
de scientifiques un environnement
scientifique et intellectuelle aux pays
bas qui fait que les études
scientifiques sont assez valorisés fait
ses études de mathématiques il écrit une
thèse en 1926 si je me souviens du titre
c'est très fort parce que ça doit être
des variables différentiel dans un
espace kovar y en a quatre variables
vectorielle vector ya des oublis et
victoria on espère heureusement que tu
es là une double espace vectoriel doublé
violemment sa part de relativité
non c'est pas ça ce que je disais c'est
que
c'est dingue différentiel espace
vectoriel quatre variables variations
différentiel de 5 c'est à dire ça
s'applique à soi l'électromagnétisme
soit la relativité en physique mais il
est l'une étudié d'un point de vue
strictement mathématique donc c'était
déconnecté de d'applications physiques
en tout cas un travail de pointe
ah oui on peut dire c'est aussi à cette
époque là c'est vraiment oui le top du
top parce qu'on en ait vraiment dans
l'est dans les théories hélas ici les
plus plus avancées au niveau de la
science mathématique
ça n'empêche pas de s'adonner à sa
passion parce qu'il connaît les échecs
depuis vingt quatre ans il est champion
des pays bas s'est interrompue de 1921
1935 et les cruels une dissertation en
allemand sur la veille de 21 à 35 ils
viennent tous les pays bas tous les ans
we will rain espère que la concurrence
n'était pas bien sûr et allons déployer
ma femme c'est toujours un mérite de
gagner même contre une concurrence un
petit peu plus faible et puis ne leur
était de s'inscrire dans la durée et
d'être tous les ans présent à
rendez-vous national c'est quand même
une grande performance ou épicier aussi
l adverbe pour les joueurs du pays
d'avoir son champion qui vient aussi à
jouer avec les autres joueurs mission
puis les cris même une dissertation en
allemand sur sur le logis des chèques
relations et christian de surcroît en
donc c'est quelqu'un qui est toujours
essayé de concilier sa passion et la
raison la raison c'est d'être professeur
de mathématiques c'est de rester un
joueur d'échecs amateurs il restera tout
c'est un joueur d'échecs amateurs ne
sont jamais un professionnel du jeu et
il arrive le dernier grand pas
maintenant c'est le dernier grand
amateur ensemble c'est fini un peu plus
leur devenir champion du monde 100 m
d'un gestionnaire et y gravit les
échelons petit à petit il se fait
remarquer dans plusieurs grands tournois
et fini par disputer le match du
championnat du monde contre un déclin en
1935 il n'apparaît pas nécessairement
comme le challenger le plus redoutable
au c'est plutôt un hommage entraînement
walking presque à la limite à l'est qui
n'auraient vraisemblablement eu des
adversaires plus dangereux comme capable
qu'un qu'il aurait pu donner la
possibilité du match revanche on ne l'a
pas fait on avait d'autres joueurs comme
rubinstein querrey ce qu'ils ont
des difficultés à rassembler la bourse
pour pouvoir disputer ce championnat du
mans bon le fait est que les kings qui à
l'époque un verset de graves problèmes
notamment liés à une consommation
excessive d'alcool a donné sa chance à
eux bien après cette chance et a réussi
à la surprise générale à battre de
justesse de son tout simplement à
lentille de justesse à notre petit point
un petit point mais quelle case et demie
14 et demi oui quelque chose de très
très très très limite sur un marathon
qui a duré pas loin de 80 partis mais
louis donc et rendez vous tenons
plusieurs mois c'est vraiment amusant et
alors on peut noter on va rappeler qu'à
cette époque et c'est la fin d'ailleurs
de ça parce qu'après ça les championnes
allemand doit être réglée comme une
horloge par la fédération internationale
d'échecs après là elle s'est juste le
dernier a fait la demande avant la
deuxième guerre mondiale
et ensuite c'est fini a par après il y
aura bobigny qui il y aura des matchs
réguliers ou les chevaux les champions
ne pourront pas à choisir deux contres
qui jouer et c'est la dernière ce
dernier match épique de cette grande
saga qui médite qui remonte à ce tennis
et ces idées au 19e siècle où finalement
le champion en titre choisi un peu sur
prétendants par une foule parmi une
foule d'amateurs à celui qui au plus
offrant quelque sorte en plus ouvert
mais financiers et pas forcément plus
offrant en termes de technologies non
oui ou alors ou à celui qui apparaît
comme étant le plus dangereux sans être
trop dangereuse peut être aussi un choix
du champion devra choisir le bon le la
personne qui est le banc sparring
partners mais pas non plus forcément le
plus dangereux c'est qu'en raison de la
fin de ce championnat à l'ancienne ou
inquiété un peu le système du duel du
système wayne c'est un peu ça on va
changer la fédération internationale été
créée en 1924 elle va prendre les rênes
du championnat du monde après la seconde
guerre mondiale donc on va rentrer dans
une nouvelle dans une nouvelle phase
d'un an vit les derniers temps de cette
époque encore assez héroïque
on va peut-être et en voir quelques
photos en championnat du monde bref on
va voir donc ce fameux max
alors ici il est à droite ou à gauche à
droite en haut à droite et à gauche
sinon cali king louis lors du
championnat du monde
c'est la revanche gagné par avic i ça
c'est la revanche sa mère avant je
gagnais par un liquide
on voit qu'il y avait encore beaucoup de
cigarettes angoissant premier plan voilà
le docteur envoie le docteur 1956 à
l'heure après leur docteur pour pour sa
thèse en matin oui mais pas docteur en
médecine d'annaba dr routy après la
seconde guerre mondiale on le voit de
moins en moins joué il participe encore
bien sûr au grand tournoi de 48 qui doit
déterminer le champion lui elle est
finie je crois 4e sur sursis sme que
c'est pas une extraordinaire performance
ici bobigny qui remporte ce tournoi
devient champion du monde il se retire
peu à peu du jeu et se consacre
davantage à un nouveau domaine qui est
celui de l'informatique ont partir des
années 50
c'est le même j'ai artistes de cette
science naissante
cette technique naissante donc il a fait
des mathématiques et de l'informatique
aussi après ce mondial
chose qui nous passionne encore
aujourd'hui alors on regarde ici
bello de 1935 on le voit ici encore
attablé en train d'analyser la partie
qu'il a disputés contre un lit king
peut-être la dernière partie qui lui a
permis de gagner et on voit une foule
qui se presse pour avoir les
commentaires du champion et elle et pour
nous c'est fini les moustaches garder
juste une petite moustache en bouchant
web c'est le public c'est lui lécher les
joueurs c'est totalement disparu mais là
c'est fini voilà alors que depuis ces
mythes il y avait encore beaucoup de
moustache et de barre de favoris et
qu'est ce qu'on veut mais rouflaquettes
mais c'est terminé sera peut-être à la
mode alors sait-on jamais alors ça ça
c'est quand même aussi un point qu'on
n'a pas encore citer c'est important
c'est une statue simon utilisé
avec un pion de mac sun au centre maxime
dolan d'un me sente qui le désirent ils
été créée juste après sam en 1982 et est
mort en 1980
donc c'est un centre des chèques qui lui
et qui lui est dédié il a eu une très
forte popularité au pays bas en devenant
champion pour les passants quand même
une petite nation
c'est un grand pays de sport est un
grand pays scientifiques mais ça ne
reste qu'une petite nation à l'échelle
mondiale et la permis aux landais qui
traversait une crise très grave qui
avait 40% de la population qui étaient
au chômage dans les années 30 d'avoir un
outil un petit rayon de soleil il est
resté assez populaire comme comme joueur
et comme homme ce qui explique
l'existence de ce max des senteurs alors
à noter parole on me wade qui voulaient
peut parler de la postérité des échecs
aux pays bas oui c'est ce que j'allais
dire dans le dire que oui que que suite
à un max heures on a une génération de
joueurs
les pays-bas très très fort donc
peut-être le plus marquant pour moi a
été gentil man qui pendant
toutes les années 70 80 et 90 encore un
peu a non seulement été un très grand
joueur mais en plus c'est d'impliquer
dans le développement d'un magazine très
important dans les échecs qui il était
rédacteur en chef et qui qui qui était
dans les tous meilleurs mondiaux il a
même été classé numéro 3 et donc il est
dirigé vers une finale des candidats
contre 15 il a dit oui je croyais bien
qu'il a fait une finale même si la mêlée
sans doute une fille à 1000 face à
kharkov dans les années 80 donc très
très grand joueur si manu qui a apporté
beaucoup et notamment dans les
ouvertures les derniers final si je
conduis très fort en finale il fait des
livres soit finalement semble bien et
puis derrière aussi martelly le clan des
vi nations et quelques autres joueurs
qui suivent la tradition donne et qui
reste aujourd'hui ne des pays bas une
grande nation des chefs tribaux et des
grandes nations des chaînes dernier
petit point
il ya un ancien grand vent tournoi qui
se déroule aux pays bas mike hayes et
oui bien sûr avec 15 et qui est
aujourd'hui s'appelle le chorus qui
s'appelait avant le
et qui est parrainée par une grande
société de sidérurgie et qui
effectivement ici depuis les années 60
très grand tournoi qui a vu tous les
meilleurs joueurs du monde passée les
kasparov et karpov et qui aujourd'hui
fait partie avec le tournoi de linares
en espagne une des deux plus grands
tournois du monde annuels et dont on est
sûr qu'ils ont lieu chaque année à la
même époque
pourtant on a des craintes et 6 en
janvier li na reste je suis en mois de
mars et les meilleurs sont là bas avec
avec andy en plus une ambiance
particulière parce qu'elle est là reste
c'est plus réservé à une élite de
quelque six ou sept joueurs ou huit
joueurs avec un deux et on a les yeux
tourner on a plusieurs tournois et les
amateurs sont alain salles que les
champions et peuvent en même temps
toujours leur parti ou lors leurs
accompagnateurs peuvent se régaler de
voir les parties des champions sur scène
et voilà c'est le premier tout meilleurs
qui vont là bas à lanzhou là bas judit
polgar jeu là bas car pauvre kasparov
j'ai pas si fischer aussi d'aller jouer
ailleurs je crois que je pense que oui
ce serait étonnant tunis open mais il
faudrait vérifier parce qu'on est direct
72 encore un peu tôt mais en tout cas
les et tous les meilleurs depuis 175 où
ils sont passés avec hands est très très
grande très grande tradition toujours
les pays bas 2 sur les échecs ou quand
on sait qu'ils meurent éléments 1980 et
le centre a ouvert en 1981 donc trois
ans après avoir quitté hafidhou il a été
actif quasiment jusqu'à la fin jusqu'à
la fin de sa vie et mort quand même à 80
ans voilà donc le grand monsieur qui
aura marqué les échecs par son état
d'esprit par son statut de dernier
champion du monde
heures donc peu en tant que champion du
monde puisque finalement c'est presque
on va dire oui à un accident de parcours
dans l'équipe mais de fait il est entré
comme dans la lignée des champions du
monde et il a râlé c'est par contre une
trace peut être encore plus grande donc
président de la fide et faut pas oublier
ça 2070 5105 18 et donc trois ans avant
son départ son ultime départ et donc on
aura marqué l'histoire du jeu d'échec
d'une double façon ce n'est pas évident
d'être champion du monde qu'on réussit à
avoir aussi une activité de
l'organisation que tout sorte autour du
jeu et on pourrait parler de polycarpe
oeuf qui s'y présentait récemment à la
présidence de la fidh et il n'a pas été
loin qui haïti a échoué alors un bon
peut-être des raisons esthétiques à bhl
ou de raison qu'on pourrait reléguer en
termes démocratique mais cela ne nous
regarde à douala alors est-ce qu'on a
une autre peut-être photo non c'est mon
but ici on revoit ses quelques photos
ici face à l'équipe en 37
oui ici donc on voit le 1956 voilà en
1935 juste après sa victoire en liquide
et enfin statufié dans son centre que
vous pourrez voir aux pays bas si vous y
passez pourquoi pas alors je sais pas si
les berges jeune club 72e dont un
qu'elle chacun ayant ses chances à noter
c'est d'ailleurs il n'ya pas qu'eux mais
quand des cas le jeu
un autre tournoi de vince li qui est une
petite ville qui est parrainé par line
et du strict et le derrière
d'ailleurs j'ai pu aller faire un
reportage là bas une certaine époque et
qui continue je prends d'avoir lieu et
qu'ils étaient bien moins grand que
celui qui a réservé une petite élite de
joueurs mais qui a duré au moins très
longtemps moi une bonne quinzaine
d'années une bonne vingtaine d'années je
sais pas si ces derniers temps je suis
pas vérifier s'ils avaient toujours lieu
il est un peu moins de prises et mais il
ya aussi cette tradition pas que on a
une forte tradition aux pays bas une
vraie tradition une vraie un vrai
intérêt pour le jeu alors on va quand
même bien sûr analyser une partie le
choeur diagonale tv ça reste quand même
le jeu de max hommes face alors un grand
joueur qui lui fait en quelque sorte la
transition avec la deuxième moitié du
xxème siècle puisque c est film génère
qui lui sera un des très grands joueurs
de l'après guerre et qui qui avait un
grand talent aussi qu'à poser d'énormes
soucis à beaucoup de joueurs où ils
étaient quelque peu de battre peu près
tous les joueurs il a une grande
carrière de joueur de genre de tournoi
aussi
dans lequel je crois les jamais devenu
champion du monde mais il fait partie de
cette école cette redoutable école si
oui alors c'est une partie qui a lieu à
zurich en 1953 donc c'est quand même
treize ans après le huit ans après le
titre de le titre de
face à la victime non c'est tout ce que
ces dissidents 18 ans pendant 18 ans dix
huit ans après placez la deuxième partie
de carrière deux ans et je vais pas dire
la fin de sa carrière mais il est moins
actif et il y ait encore des ressources
on ne le voyait moati il reste actif et
ce n'est que dix sept ans plus tard qui
va se retrouver quand même à la tête de
la fidh et donc ville et il est quand
même là dans un bon état de forme et on
va voir que ça rigole pas c'est quand
même c'est quand même du beau jeu alors
on y va
j'ai l'air démarrent la partie par des
quatre et on retrouve 4 6 7 4
aussi son nez dans les ouvertures en
maintenant un bruyant moderne avec des
choses que l'on a pu voir par ailleurs
de multiples fois dans la description
des tons or et sang qu'avait laissé
trois fous des catalans voit la foulée
car on est ici dans une niveau 1 le
signaler on est dans une liaison avec un
développement du fou particulier qui ici
clou le chaos les c3 avec l'idée misumi
tiennent de contrôle et centre parce que
si on pousse la valise salines
contrôlent plus des quatre centrales et
notamment un 4 4
on peut servir maintenant deux points
d'entrée dans le camp blanc pour le
cavalier noir
depuis les planques peut pas jouer le 4
tout de suite bien entendus pour l'impôt
pas le cas puisqu'on se ferait prendre
directement le pion sans possibilité de
le récupérer
donc ça se joue c'est elle joue c'est un
coup de côté qui vous contre le centre
alors que trois
leur seul coup tout à fait tout à fait
sain tout à fait classique 3 on prépare
déjà la sortie du four leaf un protège
ses quatre ont par contre en retard de
la sortie du futsal ce qu'ils ont et
bouchées doubles pour lui tout de suite
par son propre camp c'est simple de la
part des noirs en très bon cours de deux
là aussi de contrôler latéral du centre
on est vraiment dans les chèques moderne
toute la discussion des hyper moderne
face aux classiques a vu la victoire des
modernes et on a plus de problème à
jouer aux échecs maintenant de façon
variée soit en occupant le centre sur
l'attaquant sur les côtés sans se poser
des questions métaphysiques la même
le débat sur le débat entre classique et
moderne a été tranché dans le sens où
les hyper modernes sont devenues
classiques c'est devenu du classique de
jeu comme les hyper moderne wells et
denise l'asim ii faisons un classicisme
exactement tout à fait donc voilà alors
là ce petit coup pose la question où est
ce que tu t'es changer ce que tu recules
ça permet voilà échanges comme ça c'est
réglé et b6 sur l'art c'est très bien
alors l'idée pour les noirs maintenant
c'est d'essayer de maintenir le pion à
ses cinq ici pour garder les troubles et
en face on va éviter les changes qui
teintent de dédoubler les pions on va
essayer de jouer contre cette structure
qui est effectivement un peu maladroite
mais qui al'avantage de contrôle et
centre
il ya des avantages et des inconvénients
et en jouant des six
on met les pions sur moi pour remplacer
la perte du full cases noires donc et on
peut même jouer des six derniers pour
contrôler le 5 et le fou or so spa se
développer soit en 17 soit même des x
1,6 pour taper sur ce pion c4 qui peut
s'avérer un problème
pas facile à défendre forcément pour les
blancs dans certaines situations mais
voilà l'idée de se couper si c'est à
dire de maintenir un de contrecarrer la
perte du fou de cases noires par une
maîtrise des quatre douars via les pions
et de préparer le développement du fou
c'est alors ce qui est important aussi
bien
on pense que les blancs n'ont aucun
intérêt à prendre le pion c5 ici un nom
bien sûr lors si les blancs qui va y
avoir un maintien du statu quo
vraisemblablement pendant plusieurs
coups sur ça parce que ça s'est désolé
une erreur on voit le fiancé 5
maintenant qui en 2002 voilà ce plan de
maintien respect de deux autres pions
qui sont là par l'un des pions doublé ce
serait vraiment pas beau donc éviter
cela nous choque détient doublé ça va
encore quand ils sont groupés parce que
ça fait un mass d'audience a fait des
contrôles puissant des cases mais on le
voit par contre ici ce sont des sites ce
sont des cibles sarma pouvoir à un
attaquant pions avec le fou mais qu'elle
gérait aussi il faudra arrêter là il ne
restait que passifs c'est certainement
pas quoi faire mais si l'on ne signale
effectivement et ce genre d'erreurs
quand elles peuvent avoir lieu alors fou
détroit de la part des blancs développe
dans le peu d'êtres en sortira le câble
ayant eu deux parce que si le fou comme
fait viande mais cette le fait qu'on est
sorti le fond d'écran maintenant rien
n'est fait qu'il ya une faiblesse ici
alors il ya deux façons d'empêcher ce
fou de taper sur un sujet de son âge ou
cabaye f3 soit on veut jouer cavalier e
2-1 jouant le coup de geiler f3 voilà
les trois meilleurs extraits al avantage
c'est qu'on a une petite muraille si le
bihan qui jouent contre le coup d'essai
l'autre possibilité est un peu de jeu
cavaliers eux deux en dix ans tant pis
pour le kg 2 c'est vrai on pourrait
aussi envisager de jouer cavalier de
directement et sur fou prend 2 souffre
au projet de tour g1 et ensuite en
récupérer quand j'ai sept
le problème de cette approche c'est que
ou roque et ensuite pour les blancs
première coupe oui encore lors de
convoquer tout de suite j'ai dit ok
après pour les blancs sont ils vont tout
mon coeur j'ai bien hâte les bureaux
quai et l aurore grand roque semble un
petit peu dangereux du côté de la
structure de pions qu'on prétend éclater
ses vols ceci dit en jouant comme ça on
va pas contre le jeu des noirs qui
contrôle la case de 4,6 à l'idée music
hall et noir contre le canada donc après
la prison j'ai depuis fouet car on
laisse les noirs prendre le contrôle de
la caisse de 4 pourra consolider par des
sais qu'il faut que le fonds était
changé c'est une bonne affaire
il ya plus qu'à sortir le dernier carré
on a plus aucun problème du mois alors
avec 17 ont joué trois qui adoube
l'intéressé que ben j'ai une petite
muraille contre le fu et de jeu contre
leucate voilà aussi un intérêt d'envoyer
un contrôle minutieux des cases avec des
pions qui font attention hein bien bien
contrôlé les cases cruciale car elle et
ses six co développe victoire qu'a lieu
de ça se voit là une case aussi naturel
pour les blancs m deux bons surprotège
décale m'enfin c'est pas le sujet parce
que des cafés très bien protégé peut
aussi viser kg 3 pour protéger 4 encore
plus on peut éventuellement jouer
cavalier g3 pour venir le cadre ou même
pourquoi pas viser la z4 en attendant
mais il est bien ici en général on va
attendre un moment avant que l'europe
ça se décante avant de bouger petit rock
europe est la digne et là regardez c'est
l'heure pour le petit peloton a même
parlé un peu au début
regardez toujours pareil ça c'est comme
une faiblesse voilà une cible pour les
mois mais la condition du nombre de pas
laisser cette cible s'échapper alors
comment on fait pour cécile michaud
porte s'échappe pas on bouge pas le pion
ces cinq temps qu'on vous fasse autant
comprend pas et peut être pas de
possibilités pour se tenir debout j'ai
donc cavalia sel regard des très jolies
puisqu'on commence à attaquer le plan
c'est clair alors qui d'autre pour hâter
question de ces quatre on a le foot et
c'est bien sûr il ya le foot et sel et
ne pas oublier la tour 1 8 kg revenant
assez vite après on se sera débarrassé
de ce qu'ils ont c'est sympa mais change
pas la taille et le si l'option c4 exact
c'est à dire que étonnant que calais 5
apte à jouer on peut menacer tour s'est
vite puis une menace déjà pris dans ses
selles qui suivit de cavaliers français
cas et si les blancs avaient trouvé une
façon de défendre on peut rajouter de la
pression parfois 6 voilà un plat en noir
clair qui pose un petit problème
hollande alors les blancs se laisse pas
les bras croisés en attendant mais sur
duke lecavalier c6 est parti le
désavantage c'est par contre ça soulage
une petite pression qui a eu 24 on peut
jouer le coup suivant e4 qui est un coup
fort aussi puisque maintenant on a
regardé un très gros centre le pion on
peut jouer on peut envisager de jouer
des scènes on peut envisager de jouer le
on a des pions qui contrôlent beaucoup
de cases dans le cas inverse et donc
possibilité qu'il faut mesurer qu'il
faut juger question à chaque fois donc
ici des noirs jouent donc c'est pas à
venir vous rappelle que une vague noire
joue le coup prophylactique
ils évitent cette possibilité que celle
parc à lille 8 km à 8 k lite en position
ne peut pas s'il ici mais bon le conseil
n'a plus la force initiale et si les
blanches possède peut-être un peu rétro
par des 6 ou peut-être même f6 échanger
plus tôt du plan est fait libérer la
colonne f pour la tournoi le cavalier
pouvant éventuellement ressortiront ces
sept on peut recenser s'être une fois
qu'on a joué f6 qui on prend un essai 5
on peut peut-être revenir le gardant m6
si les blancs prennent peut-être revenir
avec kelly prend m6 voilà voilà une
possibilité alors qu'abb les g3
maintenant pour julien jeu-là continue
son développement il est l'heure celle
d'helmand rappelant des cavaliers comme
ceux de maintenant j'ai 3 ce cavalier
protège falgos aussi aux quatre très
bien protégé mais a aussi pour but de
libérer la place de deux peut-être qu'on
veut lui mettre la dame ça permet
d'avoir deux pièces à la défense qui ont
ces quatre peut-être aussi pourquoi pas
venir plus tard en 1 h 5 6 le centre de
nay s'ouvrir et que le fou était en d2
ça pourrait être un terme
ceci est lointain le cavalier pas mal je
prends tout cas mieux comme de où
finalement il a peu de perspectives
c'est prendre les cars c'est prendre un
4eme tour c'est une tour s'est vite le
pion c4 est devenu une cible
le cavalier à cinq pattes à quai
maintenant on a la tour qu'il attaque on
a deux pièces un tag sur ce pionnier une
seule pièce qui défend c'est le foot est
roi
les blancs ont plusieurs choix que ce
soit le défendre en rajoutant une unité
défensive soit leur autre chose et
laisser les noirs le grappillé
exactement alors à noter que si il est
noir au lieu de faire c'est prendre des
cas ici après calais troyes avait joué
tour ses huit pour menacer de faire ses
preuves éclats les blancs réduit
répondent par des 5 alors des cinq un
double avantage c'est que 1 mais la
prise c5 et moeurs plume donc du coup la
tour c était venu là pour rien même pas
de son propre pions et ensuite de the
bush
les perspectives du foot bessette il est
mort et donc du coup ça peut être ça
peut être un bon coup ceci dit c'était
quand même envisager cette possibilité
pour les noirs parce que lecavalier 8
pour en revenir en des six pourraient
augmenter la pression sur ses 4 et avec
l'appui de fouet à 6 on aurait même pu
envisager carrément de gagner un
championnat
donc c'était quand même quelque chose de
possible alors c'est prendre les 4
points et capté qu'une autre piste mais
on voit mal même comment les blancs
pourraient protéger le pion ces quarts
suite à cette opération puisque un coup
comme dame eux deux par exemple se
heurterait pourrait se heurter adams et
on a plus de on a plus rien pour
protéger pour protéger ces quatre là fou
c'est un empêche la venue d'une tour une
fois que le kayak et on peut même de
surprotéger soit par besset soit enlevé
cinq à surprotéger la pièce
donc ça semble extrêmement difficile
sommes plutôt que de laisser prendre les
quatre s'éprend des quatre tours s'est
vite plutôt que de s'embarrasser d'une
défense passive de ce pion qui était
quand même envisageable
eh bien j'ai l'air va tenter quelque
chose de plus direct et maître oeuvre à
l'épreuve et c'est là qu'on va voir le
talent de m
on sens où il est aussi talentueuse
savoir tenir devant une attaque il va
tenter la pâte avec elle quatre ça c'est
pas mal puisque le pion f
le tenant est soutenue bien sûr par la
tour eiffel on a regardé comme un
magnifique centre option qui fait peur
en une heure plus on peut ben voilà et
la menace c'est de vous lève celle qui
faisait cap devient possible d'alger 4e
à 10 h 5 qui bien sûr il ya le foule qui
en d3 car c'est le foot en d3 donc un
cas de en cas d'ouverture ça peut offrir
7 17 efficient excellent et puis une
fois qu'on est jouable siens qu'on peut
envisager réussissent aussi pour casser
le roc noir
il ya quand même d'envié il va falloir
être extrêmement précis si on veut tenir
cette position donc là à eux maintenant
lui bombay il voit bien cette attaque il
a il estime qu' il a largement de quoi
tenir vous tenez sous le feu est donc en
attendant il va jouer de façon très
logique et très responsable qu'avaient
les procès 4 il prend le pion ces cas là
c'est important puisque ce recueil est à
l'abandon qui joue pas en prenant un
pion on le met en jeu tout en ayant pris
un pion donc les noms ont pris un pion
en échange de quoi ils vont subir une
attaque
même pas peur même pas peur exactement
f5 attention ça démarre évidemment hors
de question d'aller prendre f5 alors ça
c'est des fautes énormes et magnifique
cavalli kasparov
on appelle ça un kamikaze temps
reflétant les scènes qui est une pièce
des normes et là on peut l'envisager dmg
quatre idées des fois le 6 tours f3 donc
eux aussi exactement tout à fait en tout
six ans ménager les taux à 3 tours h 3o
tour j'ai trois essais ça peut être des
attaques de maths très rapide alors très
bons coups de défense de m avec le coup
joli suffisant précise f600 c'est bien
donc petit coup et 6 on a une protection
du cavalier 8 qui protège le c15
importante en jouant m6 en empêche les
possibilités pour les nourrir le jeu par
m6 il faudra prendre un os si ce n'est
du coup on a une structure de pions qui
n'est pas cassée qui est solide et donc
c'est un coût tout à fait tout à fait
intéressant solide mais qui a le
problème par contre ici de créer une
petite faiblesse c'est le courage c'est
parce que pas qu'on a pas vu le 6 on
peut viser les 4e 6 ou voir la venue de
la nam une menace que la dame aurait
fait venir sur la case h4 même si elle
est un danger un jeu 88 chassé par trois
du cap bon donc c'est pas une bonne idée
mais on a en a plus possibilité tout cas
d'en vendre les des pièces facilement
alors quand même il faut noter quelque
chose c'est que le cavalier lui tient
ses cases là donc même si ce pur est
faible il pas facile d'aller le chercher
chercher une attaque là dessus il ya
aussi des possibilités de défense pour
le noir après des échanges
éventuellement centre
c'est aussi la possibilité de vous
tourner cette course est de contrôler
aussi la 7e bon on n'en est pas là et
noir en prime un pion de plus ils
peuvent aussi ramener le cas la défense
paris
existe qui fait pression sur le centre
et sur le clan le siège et les blancs
eux continuent leurs attaques avec très
bon coup tous rêvent que ça c'est pas
mal de la part de gm c'est une bonne
idée
évidemment le tout reste quatre doivent
4 l'idée est simple de geiler que c'est
de jouer soit objet câble soit une tour
h4 en conjonction avec la machette et
menacer la prochaine ceci dit grâce aux
coûts m6 c'est plus une menace de maths
droit à une petite case de sortie voilà
ça c'est le jeu d'échecs dans l'air de
rien mais on l'a sauvé alors attention
quand même parce qu'elle attaque blanche
semble forte puisqu'on appareil le fou
c'est un qui vit qui vise de rock
le foot est roi il suffit de faire une
prison de 6 et de jouer 5 et pouf une
visage 7
ceci dit on a peut-être aussi intérêt à
garder le calme il est ici parce que ça
peut éviter des idées comme a4 ou a3
voir bien des fous b2 puisque ce
cavalier domine le fou c'est un parent d
ce cavalier ici nous contrôler toutes
les cases la de sortie du fou c'est même
cette semaine mais des trois gorges en
chine et aussi la case 3 donc ceci dit
c'est pas la classe sur du mur mais ces
cases b2b à trois pourrait être des
cases attaque alors une autre
possibilité car elle pour les blocs pour
amener du matériel sans toucher aux fous
ça pourra être plus tard de jouer tour à
deux et aux rêves de patrick tôt un
simple deux verres par jour
donc attention du côté noir chez oeuvres
ont subi une véritable lancée vérité
attaque alors peuvent se démonte pas et
jouent bessin très bon coup on consolide
avec des scènes la présence du camion
ces cartes qui libérera tout ce qui est
vert la tour et puis éventuellement la
dame noire pour aller au v6 exacte et se
placer sur cette grande diagonale pour
une éventuelle contre attaque vers le
roi blanc qui forcément puisqu'il ya
plus de pièces à l'attack bien sûr
vraiment le caisson dépenses et surtout
attaque elle sans trois il ya six ans il
est noir arrivent à faire sauter ce
centre blanc
il est évident que l'attaquant aura
beaucoup moins de force puisque après
des pièces au centre facilement à la
fois contrôler la contre attaque et
pouvoir attaquer le centre et le roi et
le camp adverse
autour h4 de la part de gilbert donc je
viens augmente la pression ça y est sûre
le pion à celle d'un match 7 de venir à
noter que des coups comme h6 qui
pourrait venir à plus tard pourrait se
heurter à des sacrifices de fou
simplement une subite d'un math rapide à
noter aussi que la possibilité de jouer
carélie g7 pour détruire l'inde si le
rock le rock adverse
donc c'est très dangereux il faut être
extrêmement précis dans cette situation
et ne se démonte pas un délit c'est un
si joli imbéciles qui n'aime pas qu'un
troisième épisode même pas plus à
travailler puis on exactement
à noter que le cavalier empêche le
couffo 3 comment se prémunir de la prise
du pion des 4 si le pion des quatre
saute ensuite coup comme des cinq
explosera le centre interdite et là il y
aura plus du tout d'attaqué au contraire
ce sont les fous ça sera le fourbe et
celle qui va devenir fort contre le roi
et les noirs compris
antenne de centre donc c'est dur j'ai
retrouvé un beau coup pour défendre
depuis en d4 c'est de jouer eux 5
voilà c'est très dur d'en plus c'est
dangereux parce que là que faire pour
protéger parce que justement je veux
sicile et blanc avait imaginé un coup
comme ça fou fou bien par exemple avec
ty et surtout b1 je contrôle
ici le pire des cas très bien au sec le
ca est de la tourache carte et en plus
c'est bloquer un peu plus venir arrive
quatre pour recevoir mais qu'est ce
qu'elle va faire ici toute la partie
parce qu'elle est bloquée et en plus
difficile d'échapper adam prend des cats
soit échange des dames et chez soit
prise la toile donc attention la contre
attaque il devient extrêmement violente
donc gr un trouble une astuce
mais il est déjà en difficulté pour à
son attaque qui a été un peu olé olé
quoi parce que trop romantique le g15
alors que 5 et bien puisque en fait mais
aussi presque forcé mais si pour l'idée
est simple c'est simplement de protéger
des quatre c'est pas tellement parce que
ce pion il n'est pas protégé
non seulement il ya un prix inquiète 6
mai il est en prise aux six comme le
démontre très facilement oeuvre par le
cavalier cavaliers pro b 5 puisque le
pion est cloué par l'anam et avant la
noce au losc avec leurs premiers pions
mais en plus il peut envisager à l'état
les recettes devenir un f-16 pour
participer à la défense par exemple
venir en réussissant boucher l'avenir de
ce fou il peut aussi échangé le talent
et le fou détroit qui lui menace
potentiellement d'aller se changer en h7
et attaque blanche commence à avoir du
plomb dans l aile et le matériel est en
train de montrer un visage favorable au
noir d'autant que fut 17 et rennais est
en plus un peu fou baissait de menara
d'attac times est 6ème à la smat
si la tour c 8 arrivées à venir en ces
deux cd menace de maths aussi la tacc de
voiliers comme quoi les attaques et il
faut y aller faut toujours les mesures
et un don qu'elle prend 1,6 de la part
de geiler et jouer l'intérêt de 9.6 il
est clair c'est glacé voilà faut prendre
cette c'est pas tellement mais sûre
d'avoir plus que six points punis c'est
surtout la menace de fouquereuil set et
laissé de commencer à créer des petites
menaces contre l'autre en noir mais eux
réfléchir à capuche elle nous a surpris
price is cole puis on prend 17 mai
peuvent lui n'a pas peur il fait quand
même cavalier prend 10 3 alors là on
peut se poser la question mais attention
les indices passent sur l apprendre dès
cette année il fallait pas se tromper
l'import en génère ni preuves tpr
detroit mais attention parce que
l'attention double alors si jade si je
prends la tour gan qualité parce que
j'aimerais que ça et si je prends le
cavalier qui fait damer après je
reprends le cas légers
est-ce donc ici sur pions prend 17 il
fallait avoir calculé la suite qu'est ce
qui se passe autour nécessaire ni ton
concert pour penser un magnifique parce
que la tour est joué
salade avec loyer donc il faut reprendre
ce n'est pas le choix car les points et
l'a simplement cavaliers prendre ses
seins et le pion ne peut pas faire dame
puisqu'il ya la dame et s'il prend 1,8
très simplement alors le prouve on peut
faire dame invite enfin ça change pas
mouche l'on fait tout reprendre 8 et
après d'apprendre cavaliers pour
récupérer la pièce qui manque
on a un problème puisque on a parlé de
foot 17 qui tape son g2 on allie tour h4
qui elle peut ajouter huit mois la
défense ici est un simple coup comme le
baryum d'un de 6 pour centraliser la
dame veuve menace de me venir en e3
faire les chèques et ensuite c'est le
pion à 3 qui va être perdu ou voir même
de venir
on peut aussi attention à voir des
menaces d'al des scènes qui monast
fermathe la tour qui pénètre et c'est
les noirs qui ont davantage l'initiative
et aucune plus en plus en plus et
l'attaquent blanche totalement à l'ouest
parce que la tourache 4 n'est que
défensif sur salto parvenir à 1,4 ce
qu'elle fout si la dame tente peu réfère
à ne pas venir non elle.fr on peut pas
envoyer que les pièces dachau se
retrouve très mal positionné et l'envoie
mais l'initiative est clairement du côté
d'henry ya encore du travail dans cette
position c'est par shinya nîmes mais
c'est clairement l'avantagé noir donc
sur l francis schaller penser alors
calculer très certainement en tant qu il
va jouer cinq puis on prend 17 et c'est
mieux pour moi une amende ça marche pas
et peuvent donc montre ici de grandes
qualités de grande capacité calculatoire
en défense oui il n'a y laisse venir
même pas peur même pas peur des rockets
mme khalip en d3 d'en prendre trois
alors avec menaces même dame franchi
voilà donc le calcul gennart a toujours
l'art bon menace d'un proche cette
matrice okapi 11e alors s'il est noir
reprennent du pian ce qu'ils faisaient
mais on aura quelque chose semblable à
la partie donc on va regarder
l'entreprise simplement d'apprendre 61.6
paris menace quand même
dames 1 alors voilà l'intérêt d'armé
points 2/6 vis-à-vis de pions prendre
lors d'un jeu le prince est con on
recrée une structure de pions une chaîne
de pions exact online c'est donc une
sous tokyo unis l'avantagé d'un point de
6 par rapport par contre c'est de me
lasser matt une quasi maths parce que le
cavaly parvenir à faire région ensuite
on pourrait faire tourner français on
peut faire tous pensé exactement aucune
menace directe alors ceci dit on
n'empêche pas enfin l'idée de lillers et
d'emprunts 7 mai à prévoir 7 c'est fini
c'est-à-dire que toutes les attaques de
viol est basée sur cette idée d'aller
attaquer le courage c'est finalement se
heurte à ce magnifique cavalier de
défense bon qui est passif mais qui est
extrêmement bien passé au niveau
défensif et maintenant à l'activité
énorme du fou bessette parce que c'est
surtout ce fou qui crée la différence
tout de suite dans la partie alors les
glandes quand même fasciste pour
continuer la taxe en tout cas essayer
alors les blancs ont effectivement la
possibilité d'essayer de conclure il
faut absolument essayer de continuer à
l'être y apprenons choix donc les blancs
jouent fois ci ça l'intérêt de voir si
c'est quasiment forcé d'ailleurs cette
fois ci c'est sur toute la torah un
contrô le et donc j'évite
presque nat bon donc j'évite est cet
échec important
par contre x qui se crée pas de menace
directe sur fou prendre 17 il ya
toujours cavalli francs troll on peut
imaginer ensuite que les noirs powell
jouer cavalier h5 pour renforcer la
pression sur gsm voilà il ya quand même
tu es mon tour j'ai car exact alors il
ya quand même des menaces pour lui
lancer de jouer ça mais il faudra encore
prendre une fois un et à en faire l'un
des jeunes au gagnant lors regarder
comme le roi blanc mais des mulets à il
est tout seul parce que si lecavalier
s'en va vous voyez bien que la tour
la dame et me fous sacré quand même un
potentiel de menaces menu le seul souci
pour l'instant des noix c'est que le
retour peut pas rentrer en ces lieux
parce qu'il ya la dame h7 qui contrôle
la casse c'est exact on peut pas venir
en c2 parce que la dame qui si on
regarde il contrôle sept cadres
signifierait donc de mariée cette donne
alors on pourrait dévier cette dame
regarder pourquoi alors déjà on va
expliquer pourquoi tour ces deux parce
que la dame prendre et nous ici pourquoi
tour c'est de regarder en face en
conjonction avec le foot et cette baffe
c'est le pion g2 qui saute et 6h un vous
savez la fameuse c'est à dire qu'on
enlève la tour est inné il ya échec du
fou est nominé ou même parfois souvent
le matin donc sa pelouse moulinet passé
peut pas grand chose à part les favoris
d'halloween et parce qu'on me line quand
on arrive le tour pour aller chercher la
torah ont pour aller chercher la
torrazza alors de ce fait de ce fait il
faudrait trouver quelque chose pour
dévier la dame de la défense de la
caisse
exact donc on peut faire un élément
faites vous la main en coup les noirs
peuvent monter une attaque le contre
attaque décisive après une attaque mal
mal estimé de la part de geiler et une
très bonne défense une bien solides de
la part de huf qui quelque part le
laisse venir à ses amis un jeu de contre
que nous propose génère dans cette
partie et c'est aussi le jeu d'échec
devant le jeu de contre
surtout à partir des molaires l'ailé
mais les classiques disent aimer passe à
un ami il voulait et voulait verser les
pièces l attaque alors ici regardez
simplement magnifique très joli tout en
fuite
j'attaque la dame alors à noter que si
la dame s'en aller et on perd le fou
parce que le foot ne peut tenir là que
grâce au clonage du pion d'un clou le
qui ont dû sinon on prend avec la tour
et après tout reprendre puis on prendra
gagné une pièce net il y en a toujours
une très belle position d' attaque avec
un fou qui table sur celle du taux qui
peut pénétrer une dame qui peut pénétrer
aussi dans le code donc les blancs mais
prennent la tour saint sacrifice de tous
or l'idée pour les noirs c'est pas
maintenant de prendre le foot c'est de
jouer le fameux tour c'est un magnifique
conception de j'ai eu deux peuvent suite
à ce même très beau très beau sacrifice
de tours qui conclut une très belle
défense conditionnelle menace est
imparable pour angers 2 c'est le parent
l'on pourra pas l'empêcher donc il faut
essayer d'anticiper tout ranger deux
pour essayer de
limiter la casse après cette prise les
blancs choisissent le pont attentisme
des actifs c'est un en espérant un
échange ça arrangerait les blancs prise
prise du fou le fou protège mais
simplement les baignoires pourrait faire
échec et reprend le fou mais hull a vu
plus loin qu'ils n'ont pas pas de cette
oreille
il avait la vue encore mieux il fait
pourtant que ces deux parmi eux deux
quand même ton projet de quand même
alors à noter ici que l sais que tu
craches 1,6 euro a h1n1 c'est mort tout
simplement on fait tout reprendre j'ai
trois essais match regardé le fou fait
échec la tour protège il n'y a pas de
possibilité s'échapper pour le roy on
peut juste mettre une tour là ou là qui
va se faire manger à chaque fois par le
fou mais c'est matt donc ça marche pas
sur tout projet 2 y'a que roy elles font
pas trop le choix malheureusement le jeu
est de toutes façons de cette position
hélas pas évident à voir le clou en
effet le couloir le coût final
regardez comme d'ailleurs le roman al
saifi s'il n'y a aucun échec possible
et parfaitement les pièces blanches
autour il est dans les courants d'air
mais de ces courants d'air qui n'ont de
courants d'air que le nom que le vendée
ce qui est rien il n'y a pas d'échec car
il n'y a pas d'échec caudal donc dame
regarde est magnifique très beau très
tranquille où manquent ils soline forme
d'un b3 très jolie suffisant menace d'
avec trois échecs suivi de d'un f2 et
puis tour gym et puis il faut s 3 9 3 je
crois donc qu'il ya menace de maths en
trois comme force 3 quasiment il faut
être le courrier dans le prend et senna
donc là j'ai l'air a pas trop de choix
le seul coup qui lui reste c'est de
tenter roy e
vous pouvez vérifier à la maison c'est
il n'y a pas de coups possible et c'est
quand même dame f3 voilà comme si on
avait fait échec
il n'ya pas les chefs mais c'est foutu
comme emparé d'un f2 c'est pas que s'il
n'y a pas trop non
alors si si les blancs tentes et wave 4
par exemple le touriste a effectivement
on empêche la mecque de on attaquait
clatot est protégé par le fou mais il ya
quand même un échec en prend quand même
un effet perdu 3 et si le roi vient en
effet c'est d'alger un math et si le roi
vient d un étonnant l'idée c'est que la
tour malheureusement débouche le fou
donc on peut faire mal fraude
oui donc c'est matt de l'autre côté si
sûr d'un f3 les blancs tenté mais sur
cavaliers à chiens pour protéger la
planète de ces matins eux deux
et puis voilà c'est fini sinon un autre
coup comme 1,4 regardez la variante
c'est simplement d'un échec voire f1 est
simplement de fourrage trois cavaliers
et le roi n'a pas de case le reste
cavalli deux essais matt donc très belle
contre attaque
un très joli au comic con quand même
sacrifice de déviation temps à schwyz
magnifique superbe attaque
la dame le fou en transparence il faut
prendre la tour qui permet à la tour
noire de venir sur la case c2 et de
finir la taxe sur le bras blancs une
belle contre attaque très bien mené avec
des conceptions celle-là prises neuf
puis on s'éclate on a vu d'ailleurs que
clairement oui c'est bien le sait bien
la conception sur le début finalement
qu'il a remporté et non on réussit à
finalement mettre en évidence la
faiblesse des pions doublé tandis que
j'ai l'air n'a pas réussi à démontrer la
supériorité de son centre sur celui de
l'adversaire c'est pas très étonnant de
la part de béquilles était un grand
théoricien aussi la laisser je crois
plus de 70 livres donc 70 70 libre il ya
un ouvrage théorique très très
conséquents chez ce champion donc à lire
absolument baisser c'est peut-être pas
traduit en français tous se sont
peut-être pas traduit en français
d'accéder néerlandophones se passionne
pour revivre l'an ce lien ça pèse donc
sur les variations différentiel d espace
vectoriel à 80 yann oui c'est là trois
variables est moins intéressant
franchement voilà donc max e
scientifique que mathématicien champion
du monde et président de la fide et
pendant huit ans et qui tire son centre
en hollande qui fait partie du mythe des
échecs et qui est à la base du du
renouveau où l'explosion même
avec hollande et qui fait partie des
grands dans cet européen dans tous les
cas voilà pour cette émission spéciale
max merci jérôme insisté pamic merci de
nous avoir suivis et à bientôt
au revoir